[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
welcome friends my guest today is susan
kane that's c-a-i-n you can find her on
twitter at susan kane susan is the
author of quiet journal quiet power the
secret strength of introverts and quiet
the power of introverts in a world that
can't stop talking which spent eight
years on the new york times bestseller
list and has been translated into 40
languages
susan's ted talk has been viewed more
than 40 million times and was named by
bill gates as one of his all-time
favorite talks linkedin named her the
top sixth influencer in the world just
behind richard branson and melinda gates
susan partners with malcolm gladwell
adam grant and dan pink all good people
to curate the next big idea book club
they donate all of their proceeds to
children's literacy programs for my
first conversation with susan on the
podcast you can go to team dot blog
forward slash susan kane her newest book
which she's been working on for some
time and i know because we talked about
it last time
bittersweet
subtitle how sorrow and longing
make us whole
and i am very excited to
dig into this we'll provide links to all
the social in the show notes but you can
find everything susan knet you guessed
it susan kane.net
susan welcome back to the show nice to
see you it is so great to see you tim
thanks for having me
and i thought i would start with
this
title bittersweet which is interesting
and also funny to me on a couple of
levels am i making it up or was there a
point in your life that you had dark
chocolate
at least once a day am i inventing that
am i just making it up whole cloth
no the funny thing is that you're you're
casting that in the past tense when in
fact it's just like a constant ongoing
present
i don't think there's ever been a day in
my life that i haven't had dark
chocolate what's your daily driver
and then what are your indulgences when
it comes to chocolate do you have any do
you have any favorites or go-to's
i like luxury chocolates and all that
stuff but i don't even really need that
i just really love little
semi-sweet chocolate chips that i stick
in my yogurt and i'm happy as a clamp
and it's the little things it is the
little things
so
i'd like to start on the
sort of creative process side with
respect to the new book because i enjoy
chatting about that stuff and i'm
thinking a lot about creative process
these days for myself
so where i thought we could go and i'm
going to do a little retrospective just
like you said you're treating things in
past tense but maybe
they are present tense that's going to
be really my my first question if we
look back
at
quiet it took seven years to write if
i'm remembering correctly you had two
kids during that time
and
your your philosophy about writing is
that it's deep love that has to be
protected at all costs by the way you
can reserve the right to revise any of
these this is from the last conversation
because of that i don't care how much
time it takes
and then
asking about how you're writing
this is this is what i remember slash
i'm reading from the last time so you
take whatever thesis you're working on
then you spend a year or two just
walking around the world looking at
everything through the lens of that
thesis
and then
and i want to know what has changed if
anything asking how you organize your
notes so you stick everything in this
monstrous word doc it's like 700 800
pages by the time you're done then you
separate out things by topic putting
them into eight or nine loose leaf
binders then you organize them and try
to take advantage of emotional states as
they come up during the organization so
all this is super cool to me if we apply
this to the new project just as like a
rough scattering of concepts how did you
come up with the thesis for the new book
and then what did the creative process
look like after that
so those are two really different
questions so let's do one at a time
let's do it how did i come up with the
thesis for the new book i feel like the
only point of writing really at least to
me is
telling the truth of what it's like to
be alive you know like telling truths
that people don't really talk about in
everyday life because if they talked
about it in everyday life you could just
get it
just from chatting with your friends or
your colleagues or whomever but there's
something about
writing and art in general where
i don't know people are just like
really digging deep and
and to me the best moments in life are
also when i'm reading a book or hearing
music or whatever where i feel like oh
my gosh you know that person just
articulated something
that i have experienced and i never
really thought about it that way and i
know
exactly that person's heart and mind
like i know them and maybe they lived 2
000 years ago i still know them
with this book bittersweet i have been
feeling for my entire life
and there was an event that happened
25 or 30 years ago where i really felt
it i've been feeling my whole life
when i would hear
bittersweet minor key music you know
music that expresses the kind of longing
for some state that is forever elusive
to us
i'd hear music like that and
it's supposedly sad right minor key
music is
sad music
but i didn't feel sad i
i love that kind of music and what i
felt when i heard it what i still feel
when i hear it is
is joy
and
uplift
and
goosebumps
and a kind of love and communion and
like a gratitude to the musician that
they were able to transform
pain that all of us have in one way or
another to transform pain into beauty
and and what happened is like 25 years
ago i you know i used to be a lawyer
like that was
a whole um detour in my life oh i
remember i remember yeah and so i was in
law school and i was
and i was listening to music like this
in my dorm and some friends came to my
dorm and i was like blasting it out on
my stereo speakers
you know and the friends came to pick me
up for class
and
and they thought it was the weirdest
thing and one of them was like why are
you listening to this funeral music
yeah and i had that reaction like you i
thought it was really funny
and then i went to class and that was
the end of the story
except i could not stop thinking about
it why am i so drawn to this music and
then i started looking and finding that
turns out that people listen to the
happy songs on their playlist 175 times
and they listen to the sad songs 800
times
and it's the sad songs that give them
chills
and make us feel
connected and sublime and and
so i went off and okay this might sound
at first blush like a kind of small
question you know what is it about sad
music that could be so
moving
but
it became a much bigger quest for me
like i went off into this
five or six or seven year
quest of reading art and literature and
exploring all the wisdom traditions
talking to psychologists and
neuroscientists to figure out
what is this power of a bittersweet and
even melancholic way of being and what
i've learned is that this bittersweet
tradition it's been with us for
centuries
and
what it teaches us is that we are
creatures who are born
to transform
pain into beauty
and that's something our culture will
never tell us
i as expected to have a number of
follow-up questions of course you do
so the first you might hate this because
just like jesus ferris could get away
from the nitty gritty prescriptive
autobiographical stuff
as far as minor key music goes or music
or musicians who
utilize minor key well
do you have any suggestions for people
who might want to do a taste test
oh gosh yes
in fact i put together a bittersweet
playlist you'll be able to find it but
but i've been obsessed my whole life
i've had this deep and crazy love my
whole life for the music of leonard cohn
like i i mean i love him and i had never
actually really paid attention before to
why i love him so much i just loved him
but
when i was researching this book i came
to understand exactly what it was
because it's like his whole life
philosophy that's embodied in all his
music
is exactly what i have believed
viscerally before i had words to
articulate it i could tell you i could
tell you now what it is or we could save
it
let's jump in i will uh i'll bookmark
and come back to some other questions
that i have but take it away this is
free form he has so many different songs
but there's one line that people quote
again and again for a good reason and
and the line is
there is a crack in everything
that's where the light gets in
and
and it's like this idea everything's
broken everything's beautiful
simultaneously that's the nature of life
and there's such a truth and there's
such a relief in being able to express
that this is actually what life is
and he in turn i found out was drawing
from this tradition of the mystical side
of judaism the the kabbalah yeah and the
idea there is that
all of creation all of being was
originally
one
vessel of divine light that then
shattered
and we're living now
in the world after the shattering but
the divine shards of light are still all
around us and so like they're buried all
around us and the goal is to just be
discovering the shards and picking them
up wherever we can and
the amazing thing is that
you are going to pick up comple and
notice completely different ones from
the ones i would notice you know like to
me it would look like a lump of coal and
you're going to see like this gleaming
thing the leonard cohen line also
makes me think of and i think i'm
getting the attribution right but poetry
from roomie in fact i don't know if it's
i don't know if it's the crack it may be
the wound where the light enters us
i and i want to
come back to that sort of in in an
adjacent way
a little bit later because i want to ask
you about sufism specifically because i
believe you had some exposure
in the process of doing research for
this book and i want to ask why that's
the case but before we get there very
much so and i'm just going to interrupt
to say like so much so that i actually
have a roomy poem like sitting within
hands like so here it is
wait wait wait wait wait okay so now i
have to snap at the fly lure on the
water can you read the quote please
would you be willing to share the poem
that you have absolutely the quote is
like an excerpt from a poem so i just
want to set up the story of the poem
because it's this poem called love dogs
and it's about a man who is praying to
allah
and then
a cynical person comes along and says to
him
why are you bothering to do this have
you ever gotten an answer back
and the guy is like no you know he
thinks about it i have never gotten the
answer back and he stops praying
and he falls asleep
into a kind of fitful sleep and then
hitter who is the guide of souls comes
along while he's sleeping and says why
did you stop praying
and he says well i never got the answer
i never i never heard anything back so
it's pointless and okay and this is what
hitter says to him and this is the part
i have
inches away from me every day when i
work it says
this longing you express
is the return message
the grief you cry out from draws you
toward union
your pure sadness that wants help is the
secret cup
oh that's good yeah and i've been a deep
agnostic
atheist my whole life and i
one of the biggest things i learned from
this whole bittersweet project is that
it's such a false dichotomy this
difference between atheists and
believers and like we all feel this
longing yeah and the longing we feel is
the return message for everyone
yeah for sure and also a lot of the sort
of uh let's call it
rational materialists
might abhor
faith as it manifests in what they
consider religion
but
almost all of our lives and many of our
beliefs and a lot of our behaviors are
completely predicated on faith
that's a broader topic that is probably
for another conversation but let's let's
talk about music for a second because
the
just the existence of music
and the fact that
these kind of vibrations of sound and
different organization
can have different effects on animals
and humans and plants is mind-boggling
to begin with but
why is it do you think that minor key
music
elicits what some would consider sadness
is it just social conditioning because
we are taught early on by other people
that that is the case or is there more
to it neurologically or otherwise
so people debate this question i do not
believe it's the product of social
conditioning i i believe it's the
structure of the music itself you know
like the nature of minor key music is
that
you don't have resolution
and
and i think that's the nature of being
it's actually hard to get away from the
religion question because what i really
think is that oh i'm open to the
religion question
yeah my views have become much more
not flexible but
accepting of many facets of religion in
the last five to ten years so i'm happy
to dive right in mine too and i've
completely sensed that in you i mean
heard it from you and sensed it also i
believe that the fundamental heart of
humanity of being alive
is
the sense that there is a perfect and
beautiful world out there somewhere
and we're not in it and we've been
banished from it i mean that's why the
central
myth of western culture is you know the
banishment from the garden of eden
but you see this kind of longing for a
different world or the longing for the
beloved of the soul and the sufi
tradition you see manifestations of this
in any tradition that you look at
and what minor key music is really doing
is expressing that that's really all
it's doing it's saying
we love beauty we love truth we love
love and we can't completely have it
right now
but there's something about the fact
that we're all
stuck in this condition together of not
having it but also united in the desire
to reach for it and you know these
beautiful acts that
very deeply flawed humans sometimes take
in order to try to get closer to that
garden like that's that's the best part
of humanity and that's what the music is
saying
yeah i've
been very fascinated
in exploring music that historically
i've had almost no exposure to
for the emotions and the
gradation of emotions that they can
elicit and specifically
and i'm no musician so people feel free
to correct me
on the internet afterwards i'm sure you
will but unequal temperament music
so let's say as examples turkish music
persian music
what we might consider
arab or arabic music
have a
a range
and a level of
resolution in a sense
not resolution in the sense of finality
or answers but of fidelity
that is unlike anything i've ever heard
so it's it's produced in me
i think emotions that are very hard to
trigger
using
let's just call it modern
equal temperament music so
not not to dwell on the music side but i
do think that it is such
a
simple way to get root access to the
brain or to the emotional self it's
it's really incredible i will say though
on the minor key side so there is minor
key music i love
and for the life of me i can't figure
out why minor key piano music
specifically is just
generally speaking
punishing to me whereas what we might
consider stringed instruments right
cello etc i find
more
nourishing in some sense i have no idea
why that's the case but that is the case
for me i have trouble with the i get
sad and i want to ask you to sort of
talk about
the definition of terms right because i
would imagine people are are depre
they're people who feel grief say with
the death of a loved one then there are
people who feel kind of depressed or
despondent
and
these are distinct they seem to be
distinct things
perhaps we could just start there would
you like to just
define or put a microscope on
what you were aiming to explore
emotionally in bittersweet bitter
sweetness itself i define as
the state in which
you know you accept and you truly
inhabit the idea that
life is
always simultaneously joy and sorrow
it's light and dark there's an amazing
arabic expression days of honey days of
onions
yeah it's not good and it's also the
sense of like a like a deep awareness of
the impermanence of this life yeah it's
also a kind of
curiously piercing
joy at the beauty of things
so so it's all of this and and i think
of bittersweetness as a state of mind
that that some of us just by the nature
of our temperaments are drawn to you
from the get-go and other people arrive
there whether through life experiences
or just as they get older or whatever it
is and in the book
you can't really explore this idea of
bittersweetness without then talking
also about sorrow and longing and grief
and everything that you were just
getting at and so we can talk about all
of that but i started with this nature
of bittersweetness and what it is
and we actually we did some preliminary
studies i say we i did them with the
psychologists uh scott barry kaufman and
cognitive scientist
and also david yaden who you may know
he's at johns hopkins and he does a lot
of amazing research with psychedelics
and spirituality so he's like right up
your alley
and uh and the three of us designed
together a bittersweet quiz and did some
preliminary testing with it and we found
that people
who are in a bittersweet state of mind
are also
in a state of mind that predisposes them
to
creativity and to states of awe
and spirituality and kind of wonder all
those kinds of states so it was really
that whole suite of human experiences
that i've just been deeply attracted to
and that i feel like
we just we do not have a language for
talking about it you know and if you
look at psychology
psychology makes right now it makes
no distinction between
melancholy and depression yeah and like
and you can think of melancholy as being
kind of a synonym for bittersweetness
but you won't find it in psychology you
find it on all the wisdom traditions and
the artists and the poets they've been
talking about it for thousands of years
but
in psychology no
it's just depression that's all there is
so let me get personal for a second so
that's sort of directing the arrow back
of myself and then i would love to hear
your thoughts so as someone personally
who has struggled with depression
throughout my entire life
i think i have
conflated those two myself
and if i see
the onset or feel the onset of anything
resembling
melancholy with the exception of this
unequal temperament music which is
interesting yeah
i tend to have a panic response so i'm
like okay i'm walking along a narrow
path on the edge of i wouldn't say a
cliff but a very steep incline and if i
start to slip there's the potential that
i fall and then tumble and then off i go
right so i have this panic response so
the the question then is
what is the
value i'm just going to stand in for the
listener right like why should someone
explore this
so first of all i hear you and
and it may be i don't know that we
really know but it may be that these
states are a difference of degree as
opposed to a difference in kind and i
feel like
your reaction is suggesting that it's a
difference in degree and you're then
afraid of i'm not saying it's a rational
response it's just a kind of knee-jerk
fear reaction yeah it makes total sense
but
the value in these states of being and
i'm sure you've experienced it when you
hear that music that that happens to
speak to you like that we all have
different triggers
but the value is it's the root of our
creative impulse
the word longing like we think of it in
our culture as being a kind of passive
and helpless state like you know you're
like mired and longing you would think
but the etymology of that word is to
reach for something you know you're like
long you're literally getting longer as
you reach for something so that's that's
what creative people are doing yeah i
mean
creative people
what's motivating them they may not be
conscious of it they're like they know
that there's something more shining and
beautiful over there and they want to
bring it over here
by bringing something into being so one
thing that's in it for you you could say
is um is his creativity and then what's
the payoff susan god damn it
sorry i'm kidding oh it's good it's good
for you to ask the questions that people
are skeptically thinking to themselves
and then another one is
it it's one of the best
pathways that we have towards love and
connection
especially now when everything is so
divisive to shut ourselves off from one
of the strongest pathways we have i
think is a real
mistake yeah
i talk about this in the book and i
don't know i don't want to go in too
much of a detour but um like yeah
detour away okay three tour if you must
yeah
okay so darwin you know he's known for
survival of the people i did not see
that coming didn't see darwin coming
yes please proceed okay wait how do i
say this maybe i won't start with jarvan
oh no i like darwin i like darren i'm
just i'm just giving you a hard time
i'm just trying to figure out what's the
best way in
we are designed
physically viscerally deep in our makeup
to respond to the sorrow of other beings
and we think of darwin as being all
about the survival of the fittest and
darwin himself was this incredibly kind
of gentle and melancholic soul who was
extremely horrified by the cruelty that
that people and animals are capable of
but what he also noticed
is that
both animals and people
seem to have a kind of visceral response
to
the distress of other beings and the
great psychologist at berkeley his name
is dr keltner kind of followed this line
and he started exploring all of this and
he did all these amazing studies i'll
give you just one example
he found that we all have a vagus nerve
this is like the biggest
bundle of nerves in our body
and the vagus nerve it's very ancient
it's evolutionarily ancient as a part of
us it controls our breathing our
digestion our sex drive really
fundamental and also our vagus nerve
responds when we see other beings in
distress
your vagus nerve is reacting so this
gigantic
collection of nerves in our bodies
that does all our most fundamental
things
is also reacting to the sorrow of others
and i think that's huge you know like at
a time when everything is
divisive politics i feel like if if we
could just get into a mode where it's
like just
everybody gets to tell their stories no
no action required for a while just tell
the stories tell what you feel
and that's it
and
with a way of
tapping into one of the best and most
robust bridges that we have
you know i was also thinking as you were
talking that
part of the reason i have started
listening to this music right because
you might ask well if you're so afraid
of slipping why are you listening to
this music yeah that is great
and the answer is
i feel like
having had some exposure to it and
having not slipped
that
and this is not going to be the best
comparison or
phrasing to use but there's this
expression you know the more you sweat
and training the less you bleed in
combat
and
i also feel that in this instance if
you're afraid of slipping
if you're going to have a
panic response
when you encounter certain emotions
for me at least i am trying to
almost like io cane powder in the
princess bride like
to expose myself little by little so
that when it happens and of course it's
going to happen you're human like people
are going to die tragedies will occur
love will be lost things will happen
that
i'll be more resilient in the face of
those inevitable
times
by
inoculating myself in a sense and then
pursuing it that way i ended up enjoying
a lot of this music which i did not
expect
and
that's kind of how i ended up
where i am i would i would love to
talk about or have you describe the
research a bit
and explain where
sufism
comes into it and
my understanding which is very very
minimal but
or i should say my attraction
to sufism and other let's just call it
like mystic or mystical traditions is
that
for me at least it describes more of a
direct experience of what they might
term the divine as opposed to an
intermediated
kind of religious structure that is
predicated on certain power dynamics
within like a human organization right
so the direct experience
and i just would love to know how on
earth
sufism came into the picture and what
other things came into the picture
i like your description of mystical
traditions in general i i think they
appeal to people who for whatever reason
are allergic to dogma
tend to be skeptics or whatever it is
like you know people who aren't just
going to accept
something because it's written down
you're like you want to think for
yourself you want to experience it for
yourself
so there's that aspect of
and i am that type of person i drive my
husband crazy sometimes as i say because
like you know
i'm the person where if you say x i'm
thinking well what about why you know
and that's just how my brain goes
but that wasn't really
that aspect really did get me interested
in mysticism in general
but sufism in particular
guess what happened was i mean first i
met some sufis and then as i started to
learn about it
this one sufi teacher his name is
llewellyn von lee
whose videos you can find all over the
internet amazing name it's an amazing
name and he speaks in just the
gentlest
most lilting
welsh inflected accent he's just
mesmerizing to listen to
and somehow i found his videos
because when i met these sufis i got
really interested in this question of
sufism and longing and you know
unlocking is the thing that i've been
feeling all my life that i couldn't
explain
and anyway he he says
sufism
was at first heartache
only later was it something to talk
about
oh
say more about that please
and just for those people wondering
llewellyn i'm not even going to try to
spell just throw w2l's ew the von lee
is i thought it was v-o-n it's
v-a-u-g-h-a-n
hyphen l-e-e
so could you say more about
what you just said just to expand on
that a bit
you find the following idea
in all the mystical traditions
that longing carries you closer to the
divine
so the heartache that you feel
luella and von lee would say
we often mistake
as depression we mistake our sorrow
sometimes as depression when what it
really is is a longing for
whatever you want to call it you know he
would call it the beloved of the soul
but i call it the perfect and beautiful
world
dorothy in the wizard of oz calls it
somewhere over the rainbow but we all
have
that and and there are a thousand
different words for it like i
in every culture you find it and i i
talk about a lot of them
in the book but we all come in with this
kind of
fundamental heartache that we mistake
yeah
i don't mean to say that people who are
experiencing depression that it's not
real i'm not i'm not saying that at all
i'm just saying there's this other
dimension
ever experienced i was also just
thinking you know what you're saying
could be
general in the sense of somewhere over
the rainbow or longing for the beloved
of the soul
and we
mistakenly label that as
depression right which can have many
causes depression biochemical could be
event-based any number of things
but also you could have a longing for i
was just thinking like
connection with close friends yes and
feel the symptoms of that deficit and
then mistakenly label it as is
internally generated isolated depression
whereas in fact you're just longing for
something that is deeply
treasured or nourishing to you whether
you realize it or not
i think that's right and i think because
our culture doesn't really
we we don't have a language for longing
even though in the christian tradition
the most quoted line from saint
augustine is our heart is restless till
it rests in thee
so
as i say you find this in every single
tradition this is a deep aspect of being
human but because we
just have no
language or concept for it in
contemporary culture
it actually ends up
causing a problem in our love
relationships because
the same longing that we have for
perfect and unconditional love
from our loved ones and our friends
that's just a different manifestation of
this fundamental longing that all humans
come into the world with and so when we
get
frustrated with our partners or our
friends because they have this foible or
that one or they're not understanding
this thing about us
or that thing
yes there's concrete issues to work
through but sort of underneath it
there's also this feeling of like you
know i thought you were gonna be the
garden of eden and you're not
and so understanding this aspect of
ourselves is can be very illuminating
for our daily lives too
you mentioned earlier in this
conversation the
relationship
between
this
longing
or even sorrow
and creativity could you
elaborate on that just flesh out why you
believe that to be the case any examples
that come to mind just
speak a little bit more about how
creativity could be the product or
byproduct of these things
with creativity
there there's a long kind of
intellectual tradition of thinking about
i i've sort of noticing the association
between
creativity and a kind of sorrow you know
there have been studies done that have
shown that many highly creative people
like a wildly disproportionate number of
creative people were once orphans were
orphaned when they were children
then there's another study where they
they took a group of volunteers and they
had these volunteers give speeches
and half the people gave speeches to
audiences who were told in advance that
they should
smile and clap and applaud
and then the other half gave speeches to
frowning audiences who seemed incredibly
disapproving and
and after
it was done you know just as you would
predict the people who had given the
speeches to the disapproving audience
they said they were in a bad mood
and the other ones the other ones were
feeling kind of pumped up and then they
asked
these people who had given the speeches
to make collages which they had
professional artists rate for creativity
later on
and they found that the people who had
given
the speeches to the disapproving
audiences created more creative you know
better rated collages
and that this was especially true for
people who came in with a kind of
hormonal profile that seemed to
predispose them to emotionally
vulnerable states
so you know there there's a lot of these
different kinds of of studies that we
can look at and at the same time you
know there's also data showing if you're
you're truly depressed you're actually
much less likely to be creative because
depression is such an emotional black
hole that sucks up everything
but i think there's something about that
in between state
where
you're not depressed so you're still
you're functional
but you're acutely aware
of the gap between the
desired world and the one that we
inhabit
and the desire to fill that gap that's
really the creative impulse um you know
if you look at my my favorite leonard
cohen like he would talk explicitly
about that being what drove him and
his son adam cohn talks about how
his whole idea was that this world is
it's beautiful and it's broken and what
he was doing with all his songs that
they were a kind of transcendence
delivery machine like just the way
cigarette is cigarettes are a way of
delivering nicotine in this case it's
music delivering transcendence to people
who are inherently broken and beautiful
so i am going to ask you not yet but i'm
going to let this gestate for a minute
or two so i'm going to ask you
about
what methods or tools or resources
people can use if they want to explore
some of those in between states
and since you mentioned music i want to
bring up
a specific piece of music and
i'd like to ask you about it and
probably the first thing i'm going to
need to ask is how on earth you
pronounce these names
but let me you're going to love this
butchering and then i'll let you fix it
if i know how
so the song is called
okay
so
there we go
so
i want to know how you found this i want
to know
why it had an impact and how it had an
impact and then use that as a segue into
approaches people can take tools
experiments anything at all for
exploring some of these in between
states okay that was a whole lot of
questions so i'll do it so the first
part is
this particular song just tell me all
about it and then
after that what might people do if they
want to explore these states sure okay
so this particular song you know so i'm
in my 50s so
i was living in new york city back in
the day when there was still you know
those virgin
mega store
music places
and you would go into them and
i've always loved what they called world
music you know like music from all over
the place and it was always at the back
of the store and i would go to the back
of the store and they had these
listening stations
and i would just go from one to the
other and find stuff and and i found him
that way i found it on that way and
somehow
you don't have to say the last name do
you know i believe it's reichel
okay i-d-a-n last name r-a-i-c-h-e-l
c-h-e-l yeah for people wondering yes
for people wondering and he's he's just
this amazing guy who i've gotten to know
and he collaborates with musicians from
all over the world and
he always places himself very much on
the margins and in the background and
showcases all these other musicians who
he's collaborating with it's just this
really generous soul
but this particular song
i don't know if there's a way to play it
actually as part of this podcast maybe
we could man well if you know him i do
yeah yeah yeah so why don't we do this
yeah please if just make a note to email
him and see we'd have to probably get
some release or something but
if he's open to having us play the song
that'd be that'd be amazing i would love
to do that okay okay
i bet he would be open i'm guessing he
would be open to it and i really hope
you all can hear it because
it's so stirring and it's basically
means here comes
my bride here comes my beautiful one
here comes the person i'm longing for
and that's hebrew it's in hebrew yeah
but also part of the song is sung in
amharic if i'm pronouncing that oh
language correctly i'm harik
really
well yeah as i say he's like all over
the world was it aramaic or amharic
is egypt i think
i think it's ethiopian though i may be
totally wrong
yeah yeah ethiopia yeah okay no amharic
is the written language is amazing
and it should be ethiopia afro-asiatic
language of the southwest semitic group
and on it goes yep
very cool that's awesome okay cool so
it's hebrew and hamark yeah and this
song it's basically like a version of
the song of solomon you know it's
basically saying like here comes here
comes my beloved she's coming to me
across the desert and
and it's a love song it's a really
interesting thing about this and i'm
i hope we can get the music because
you'll hear it in the music
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so this comes back to our sufism
discussion because
also according to luella and von lee the
sifi teacher i was talking about what
happened is
that
the sufis had always used the metaphor
of the love of a woman
as a metaphor for the love of god and
then what happened is
the crusaders came
east and heard these expressions and
then they brought them back into the
tradition of the troubadours who then
kind of used that way of speaking and
singing to you know like serenade
maidens underneath moonlit windows
and i love that because it because it's
telling us that that impulse to
fall passionately in love with another
human is actually the same impulse as
falling passionately in love with
whatever you consider the divine to be
there's no real difference between them
and and you're going to hear all of that
in this song and all of it is expressed
through longing and once you become
aware of your longing i'm telling you
like you won't be able to listen to 75
of your playlist without hearing it
because that's what's driving most music
i'm excited to dig into this i'm also
excited
to hear
more um i've spent some time
in ethiopia
but i haven't heard much spoken in the
last 10 i've certainly heard very little
music
and
you know how i was mentioning earlier
i've been listening to a lot of music
from the middle east
including
persia
q
khafuz and other poets right yep
i don't think it's a mistake that the
longing we're talking about is so well
represented
in
these
places where we're finding poets who
were citing but also the exact
locations or origins of the music that
i'm listening to
and
i wonder how much of it comes down to
the language itself on some level
because amharic is a semitic language
like arabic
so it has similar structure
similar prefixes suffixes i wonder how
much of that longing is
or lack of longing is a sufficiency or
failure of language because you for
instance and this is not an example that
translates to these
other examples but if you go to brazil
they may have the same word in portugal
but saudaji
yeah sure so
or you know japanese they have
natsukashi which is
is quite different but
and mano no
uh totally that is a really cool one you
know i recently put this in
five bullet friday
i mean my newsletter because uh someone
had had brought it to mind do you mind
if i
take we'll just do like a little sidebar
on mononua i love no no no worry yeah i
think i talk about it in the book it's
and i think i saw it in your newsletter
and it's like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no go for it go for it no
no go ahead i don't remember what you
said in the newsletter but i remember it
speaking to me i probably just grabbed i
thought the wikipedia entry did it did a
good job so
the mono no aware
is the pathos of things exactly but it's
also translated as an empathy towards
things or a sensitivity to ephemera
which by the way cue shintoism if you
want to
really
pay attention to shintoism and if you're
like shinto isn't what the hell is that
if you ever have read
any of marie kondo's stuff her name is
actually marie but mario kondo stuff on
talking to your objects and
thanking your belongings and so on this
is actually a good example of what we're
talking about sensitivity to ephemera is
a japanese idiom for the awareness of
impermanence which is called mujo
in
japanese it's also
by the way could mean
non-ordinary
mujo
or transients of things in both a
transient gentle sadness this is or
wistfulness at their passing
which is very similar to saudaji
as well as a longer deeper gentle
sadness about the state being the
reality of life
all of that is encapsulated into mono no
aware
and when we have those cherry blossom
festivals and the whole reason that as i
understand
that the japanese love cherry blossoms
the way they do like
they're very beautiful but it's not that
they're the most beautiful flower it's
that they're beautiful and they're
ephemeral so
that's exactly right
brings up the state that tim was just
describing like the gentle sadness of
impermanence perfect example that is a
perfect example yeah so the sakura or
the cherry blossom viewing which is
hanami
is for a very short period of time very
very short period of time in japan and
that's exactly right yeah this this
impermanence is something that
at least
my experience is very heavily present
in japanese culture mythology
and to a lesser extent the language i
feel like you might be suggesting well
you know like i'm seeing this a lot in
japanese culture and i'm seeing it a lot
in in certain middle eastern cultures i
would say from what i've been
you know my walk around the world that
i've done for the last few years that
it's in all cultures and it's just
expressed differently differently in our
culture it's there and it's just kind of
buried
for example the the ancient greeks had
this word potos which i may be
mispronouncing but it's p-o-t-h-o-s
and it basically meant the the longing
for that which is beautiful and
unattainable
and for the ancient greeks they
understood that that state of being was
active and not passive so
odysseus at the beginning of of the
odyssey of homer's odyssey you know that
that poem basically starts with him
weeping on a beach with homesickness for
his native land so he's in a state of
potos
he's described that way
and that's the state that then ignites
this whole epic adventure
that western literature is premised upon
and alexander the great was said to be
seized by potos when he like looked out
at a riverbank or something and thought
of all the lands that he wanted to
conquer
so it's not my favorite example but
there you go
[Laughter]
takes all kinds yeah
so there's really no culture that you
look at that doesn't have a way of
expressing this idea
i agree with you some more elegantly
than others perhaps but i think the
feeling exists whether we like it or not
so given that we have thousands of years
of
creatives and artists it would make
sense that
likely being attuned or at the very
least interested in these things
they there would have been expressions
of it in these many disparate cultures
my question just to bring it back to the
second part of my very long
like 17 part question
for people who may feel like they don't
have access to this or haven't
experimented with it what can they do
what are some options so there's a few
things that you can do if you think
about the way that looking at the cherry
blossoms or really looking at anything
that's beautiful can
make you cry from a sense of being moved
the reason that we're crying usually is
because deep down
it's triggering in us this sense of like
oh my god this thing is so beautiful but
this world that we live in actually is
not really that except for brief moments
so
just this the state of being immersed in
beauty is one of the best things that
you can do and i i will tell you i
actually had an experience like this
myself during the pandemic so
at the start of the pandemic i was very
much
in the habit of waking up and doom
scrolling on twitter
and
and i also i lost my father and my
brother
to covid
i'm so sorry i didn't know that quite
early on in the pandemic so all this
stuff was happening and i decided that i
was gonna it wasn't even
i don't know why i did this it wasn't
like i had a programmatic reason to do
it but all of a sudden i decided i was
gonna start following
art accounts on twitter and i just like
tweeted and said what should i follow
and the next thing i knew like my whole
feed was full of art
and then from there i started
posting art almost every day now on my
social media i start my day by posting
favorite art and together with like an
idea that i'm thinking about or a quote
or whatever
and it's become a just amazing daily
practice
that i'm sharing with people all over
the world which is so cool
which is a long way of saying one thing
you can do is immerse yourself
consciously into a state of beauty
haven't you done that also when
writing
finding locations
that are
beautiful or attractive hasn't that also
at some point maybe it still has been
part of your writing process yeah wow i
can't believe you remember that
so yeah i mean pre-covert it used to be
in cafes because i love so much cafe
energy it's just like my happiest place
in the world and i don't do it so much
now so now like i'm here in my office
it's a pretty good-looking office
nonetheless yeah and so i've created
this other thing like i have
so i have my candle and that's the first
thing i do when i come in in the morning
i like that
i always have my latte because that's
magic for me and then i have this thing
i will show you
this is a whole story in and of itself
but when i first met my husband i had
just
stopped practicing law
and
i wanted to be a writer and he had just
come from
he had spent the 90s working for the un
doing peacekeeping and
like the world's worst war zones of the
90s and he'd published this memoir about
it it was like amazing
and at the time
all i had really done with my writing i
was writing this memoir in sonnet form
because that's what i was doing
and that's hard
[Laughter]
yeah and i and like i show and i told
him about it i showed up at our second
date and i handed him some poems that i
was working on
and then that night
he went home and he sent me this email
which i now have printed out in my
office so i'm going to hold it up but
i'll read it in case people are
listening but all right okay oh i hope
people are listening
oh i mean like in case people can't see
the video that's right
wait i'm actually thinking this isn't
even going to come through in the video
it's that well it's gonna
oh that's funny i can only i can only
see a little bit it actually looks great
i can i can piece it together memento
style but why don't you read it okay and
we'll go from there
it's beautifully framed and just to be
clear it is not a printed out email it's
actually been formatted with typography
and really really jumps or did he
actually make that well i mean the email
like all these gigantic
letters in big bold red that you see
that was what the email looked like oh
it was in the email wow over achiever
go for that guy he's the brand kind of
person okay
it's like the crazy eddy email all right
reference for people from long island
yeah go for it yeah i recognize that i
grew up in long island too
so
he wrote this is in response to these
poems he wrote i want more give me more
i know i know you hate to be told what
to do but [ __ ] you keep writing drop
everything
right
right woman right
and the right woman right that's like in
the big red letters
oh
god i need one of those maybe i can
see on fiverr can i hire him to send me
an insistent email about writing i could
really use it he's very motivating he
will do it yeah creating a sanctuary
space you know where
whatever is beautiful to you or moving
to you
are you in new york city at the moment
actually not i'm outside new york city
outside new york city
so pre covid were there any favorite
spots
in or around new york just in terms of
beauty for working just curious if you
had any favorites oh
my gosh i mean i wrote all of quiet in
the world's
most magical cafe and you know talk
about longing i just feel like for the
rest of my life i will be searching for
a cafe that you know it's like my
jerusalem what's the name of the cafe
well it doesn't exist anymore that's the
problem
i used to travel so much before covet
and every city i went to i would be
looking for a replica of this cafe and i
can't find it it was called doma which
means home in czech it was owned by
czech people wow
and
it was beautiful and it was also
frequented by like
the world's most uh just creative and
thoughtful souls and you could just feel
them as you were there you know typing
away in your head so all right somebody
doma find it d-o-m-a is that right
c-o-m-a yep all right you can find
photos online find some video
the world wants it or at least the two
of us do
all right so exposing yourself to beauty
yeah
creating a sanctuary space
what are other
options music we've talked about
and we'll we'll include a link to your
playlist in the show notes
any other suggestions or even
recommendations for how to think
about this
if someone has made the leap from
i don't want to feel that too
maybe i should feel that i wonder what
it would be like to feel these things
any other suggestions so another one is
captions and i'll tell you what i mean
by that
there was this viral video and it was
put out by the cleveland clinic hospital
and um and it was originally meant to
just be
a video for its caregivers to teach
empathy
but it ended up going viral and
and the way this video worked
it basically took you on a visual tour
down the hospital corridors so you're
just passing
all these humans
and these are people who you would
normally just walk past in the corridor
without really thinking that much
but in this case the video had captions
underneath each one telling you what
they were experiencing at that moment
and in some cases they were experiencing
something joyful like
just found out he's going to be a father
i think is one of them
but because it's a hospital more often
the captions are things like
a little girl visiting her father for
the last time
or you know just found out that the
tumor is malignant or whatever it is and
maybe we can link to this also in your
show notes oh for sure
we'll find it yeah i mean you can't you
can't watch this video without
tearing up but it's but it's more than
the tearing up
you can't watch it without having that
physical sensation of your heart opening
up it's like it's just opening and the
lesson for me of that video and i try to
do it now
when i just walk around
is think well what are people's captions
you know just random passers-by like the
you know the person who's checking out
your groceries what are her captions
and it's just an
incredible way of kind of
letting
sorrows in you know and normalizing them
yeah
which also reminds me like another
concrete thing i think people could do
in the workplace
so we know one of the studies i talk
about in my book
was done by two people named jason
kanoff and laura madden and they looked
at people's description of their work
lives
and what they found is people would
describe to them
all these you know like terrible things
that had happened to them at work
and the stories revealed how terrible
they were but when they described their
emotions instead of saying they had felt
anxious they would say they were angry
and instead of saying they had felt sad
they would say they were frustrated
and we need a way of opening up this
language because
i noticed this the other day i did a
talk about introversion in this case
it was like a zoom call
for a company
and at the beginning of the zoom call it
started out the way it often does with
like a nice chat
and and somebody asked the question like
how's everybody feeling this morning you
know and and all the answers were like
pumped you know yay i'm feeling great
i'm energized happy
and
and these are all amazing emotions i'm
not trying to take away from them
it's just you have to ask what are the
chances that every human
responding
in that chat box was truly feeling
only those emotions what are the chances
of that yeah they're actually incredibly
low
i believe there are ways for
workplaces to
normalize the expression of all of the
different emotions that we have
you know even by something as simple as
in in a physical workplace where people
are really showing up you know having
like a board up on the wall where people
can just write down that morning what
are you actually feeling what are you
actually going through like in schools
they call that a parking lot and i think
we need a parking lot in workplaces too
i didn't realize i didn't have one of
those growing up yeah exactly so there
are schools where they actually have a
blackboard or whiteboard where kids
write down how they're feeling
yep
this might be a good
segue for talking about sort of
kids what kids are feeling and then of
course as kids age they turn into these
things called grown-ups and sometimes
grown-ups have kids
this is going somewhere don't worry
i know you have written about
in some respects inheriting the grief
or griefs of our parents and ancestors
could you speak to that
and
also mention if there's anything to be
done right or is it just like having
you know genetics for
like small calves and you're like well i
mean i can go to the gym but they're
always going to be pretty small
or is there something that we can do
with whatever we have
accumulated through our bloodline
i
went down this whole path of looking at
inherited grief and i ended up devoting
a whole chapter of the book to it
because
originally it was just because i went to
this seminar for bereavement counselors
because i was just curious to learn more
about that
and what i found was
we were each asked to tell a story of
loss that we had experienced i really
didn't want to tell my story because i
felt like it wasn't as bad as some of
the other stories that i i heard that
day and i felt
wrong to be talking about it but i felt
like i had to because it seemed
ungenerous you know not to tell my story
and then when i did i found myself
crying much more than anybody else had
and
and the seminar was run by this
incredibly skillful guy named simcha
raphael it was at the new york open
center
and
i forget how he came to it but he
basically said to me
that i seem to be
carrying a grief that was like apart
from what i personally had experienced
that i was carrying a deeper grief than
that
and that it was a kind of grief of the
ancestors and
and i started realizing that
well i mean i i come from this family
that's kind of
mired in loss really
you know on both sides of my mother's
side and my father's side we lost almost
all of our relatives in the holocaust
and although those weren't people who i
knew directly there's kind of a shock
wave that
reverberates through
when he said that i realized that
i had always had this kind of tendency
to
even when i was a kid to cry at any kind
of moment where it was like
that which once was will never be again
even though at that point i had not
really experienced any loss in my life
and i had a happy life i still had this
intense reaction
and once he opened up that idea i
started
researching the whole
area of inherited grief it's like
it's absolutely fascinating you know
like there's all this research that
finds that
that the children of holocaust survivors
have particular biomarkers
that you wouldn't find in another
control group population um and you can
find this in animals too it's a pretty
it's a pretty new
area of research but the results are
incredibly compelling
there seems to be this
this idea this thing that we can
inherit from the people that came before
us and you know in a way the question of
whether it comes to us biologically or
because of what we learn from our
parents culturally it almost doesn't
matter we're inheriting it somehow
and then to your question of what can
you do about it i have found it
incredibly empowering to know this
because
there's a way in which you can get to
the inside of i'm gonna love those
ancestors and i'm gonna feel
empathy for that which they experienced
at the same time that you're holding the
idea that their story is not my story
and i don't think we
take the time to realize that you can do
you can hold both those truths at the
same time their story is not my story
and yet i love them these people i've
never met before
i guess because music has been our theme
here there's this amazing song also by
dara williams it's called after all
and she it it's a masterpiece of a song
and it describes how she had been beset
by a kind of mysterious depression and
to come out of it she traveled down what
she calls the whispering well
of talking to her parents about
her family history and realizing all the
different things that she was carrying
from the people who had come before her
and how that process of excavating all
of that and understanding it and loving
it that was what freed her and then she
comes out into a kind of like shining
light on the other side and it
it helps her with her depression so you
know whether we're doing that through
some kind of formal therapy
or through
our own sort of ad hoc process of
traveling down the whispering well there
are ways to do it
we don't have to take this
right turn because it could really
uncork pandora's box but
this is part of
one facet
of exploration in looking at psychedelic
assisted therapies
is
multi-generational
trauma or
ancestral grief
and
i also wanted to mention
lest anyone listening
think who are these whack-a-doodles this
sounds like some new agey [ __ ]
i did a quick search just to pull it up
because i know it exists
here's an example this is in scientific
american fearful memories passed down to
mouse descendants genetic imprint from a
traumatic experiences carries through at
least two generations exactly and then
this is from nature magazine
which is also a very
respectable steam publication
and
there are in other words animal models
and
scientific studies and peer-reviewed
literature that supports this
in
various species of animal including mice
and the authors suggest a similar
phenomenon could influence anxiety and
addiction in humans
now there's a lot of skepticism i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna read a little bit
of this very quickly
some researchers are skeptical of the
findings because a biological mechanism
that explains the phenomenon has has not
been identified i am kind of skeptical
of such skeptics because
we all use for instance microwaves every
day but very few of us understand how
microwaves or refrigerators if you don't
like microwaves how they work right so
in the absence of a mechanism this is
also true for a lot of commonly
prescribed medications we still don't
actually understand how they work but
putting that aside so according to
convention this is going back to the
article the genetic sequences contained
in dna are the only way to transmit
biological information across
generations random dna mutations when
beneficial enable organizations to adapt
to changing conditions but this process
typically occurs slowly over many
generations
yet some studies have hinted that
environmental factors can influence
biology more rapidly through epigenetic
modifications which alter the expression
of genes
and it goes into
many more examples and so on but there
are a lot of scientists very credible
scientists including looks like
many quoted in this carrie wrestler
neurobiologist and psychiatrist at emory
university
who have studied this in
animals and i want to say someone could
call bs on this but i want to say that
it's even like this biological material
can sometimes be transferable from one
animal to another
even if they're not direct descendants
so if you use the electrical shocks
to produce a state of acute anxiety and
learned helplessness in mice when you
turn off the lights that there is some
way of transferring
genetic material from that animal to an
unrelated but same species animal that
will induce
a similar
fear of the dark even though it has not
been learned so
there is in other words a biological
basis there seems to be a biological
basis for what exactly what you're
talking about right because the
holocaust in the grand scheme of things
is the example you used not that long
ago right really just not that long ago
so
i want to offer
two other ideas of ways to cope with
that yes please if you're listening and
you're thinking oh you know this
actually might speak to my experience
one is just kind of a simple reframing
that rachel yehuda who was the the
researcher who first discovered this
epigenetic tradition in holocaust
survivors
she talks about how
one of the people she who she worked
with she started to understand
this in herself and she started to
reframe when things would happen to her
like she'd have a bad day of work and
kind of overreact
she started saying oh well i now
understand that you know my shock
absorbers are a little thinner than
somebody else's might be and so i'm just
gonna adjust around that and you know
this the simple knowledge and acceptance
is an incredible power
but to take it even a step further
beyond that i talk to a lot of people
who
are what you might call wounded healers
which is a kind of archetype
in the western tradition people who have
experienced some kind of wound or pain
and then
use that to try to heal the same pain
that they see other similarly situated
people
experiencing
and i talked for example i write about
this in the book with uh
the young woman who i called farah katib
she didn't want to use her real name
she's from the middle east and she felt
that
she didn't just feel she she came from a
family in which
all the generations of the women before
her
had
had suffered these horrible experiences
of rape and bereavement and all all
kinds of things
and um and she just found herself like
called she she had some
job for a multinational company doing
marketing or something
and as part of that job
they had to do that thing you do where
you do lots of focus groups and listen
to people's stories
and as she listened to the stories of
other women
there was something in those stories
that touched this nerve in her of all
the generations who had come before her
of women and her family and she found
herself leaving that job and flying back
to the middle east and starting to work
with women prisoners and then starting
her own not-for-profit um to help women
refugees and there's something about
that work that she's doing to help heal
other people that is simultaneously
healing
herself
and with all of this i also want to say
at the same time it's not like
you know that's kind of a grand story
and when when we talk about creative
people who transform pain into beauty
you know and they turn out to be leonard
cohn that sounds like really grand also
but you don't have to be doing these
things on such a grand scale it's just
like
you can be doing them on the most minute
level and you're still going through
that same mechanism of taking pain and
turning it into something else it's the
mechanism that matters
you know i've thought i end up maybe
somebody can get me off my ass and
actually
you suggest some resources i've i have a
very close relationship with my dog
she's very well trained very calm and
i've often thought about volunteering to
take molly my dog through say
hospice care or senior centers and i
just haven't had the bandwidth to figure
out the logistics
of doing that and i can understand why
hospital administrators probably don't
want just every rando coming through the
hospital with their dog which makes a
whole lot of sense but it doesn't have
to be big and i do think at least for me
trying to help other people heal
has been a huge part of my own healing
yeah i've really seen that in you
oh thank you
yeah it's been um
it's been it's been quite a fascinating
road and i also want to give rachel
yehuda credit where credit is due on
another level she is at the forefront
of
using mdma-assisted psychotherapy
for veterans
and is involved in a number of different
capacities so she really is
an acute
and astute
observer
of the human condition within the
context of
trauma and intergenerational trauma
one of the people out there who i think
is really doing outstanding work so i
just wanted to give her
give her credits to yeah give her her
shout out and you may have already
answered this i apologize if you have
but
it's a lot of work to do a book it's a
lot of work to do any book and
as we've already covered you take your
time you really
immerse yourself saturate yourself in
exploration
and travel far and wide
it's a lot to sign up for
why do that with this book
i do it because i would
not rather be doing anything else
that's very good answer
i love doing it you know i'm usually
like
drawn by
some question that i'm driven to answer
and i've noticed i i didn't actually
set out to do the following thing when i
was writing this book but i realized in
the end that
there was a similarity to what i had
done with quiet which is it's a kind of
the identification of a hidden
superpower that our culture
doesn't
normally talk about
but you know the superpower of being in
touch with the simultaneous joy and
sorrow of life
i believe it's one of the deepest
superpowers we have
when do you ever get to talk about it
so that motivates me
and i think just the act of creating
something beautiful whether you pull it
off or not almost doesn't matter just
that attempt to do it i don't really
know any better state of life
than that
here here and i just want to point out
this happens a lot you're not going to
be able to see it if you're just
listening to this but so i just
mentioned my dog molly i thought you
were petting yourself she
just came down
after the mention to say hello so she is
a love
she's got a good radar
my external nervous system as i often
joke although it's not really a joke we
may have touched on this in the last
conversation but if not and even if we
did we can always state it again
books that you have gifted most to other
people
anything come to mind
there's one that i actually gifted to
you that i especially love
what the heck was it called it was like
art is the highest form of hope
yes i love that book that's exactly
right that's a fadon book i think if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
yeah beautifully made
i have that on my coffee table in austin
yeah and it's basically for those
listening it's basically just this book
of quotes from various artists
art is the highest form of hope yeah i
don't know if there's any quote that
sticks in your mind from that book i
don't want to put you on the spot but
well i mean i'm just looking at
in the
title itself is
a first line expressed by the german
painter gerhard richter in 1982. i quite
like the marquee lights title quote
you very kindly gifted this to me
probably what it would have been a few
years ago i think so and i went through
and i've highlighted all of my favorites
but i don't have them in front of me
do you have any favorites that come to
mind
i do
and i think i even quoted this one in
bittersweet
and it was
it was a quote by mark rothko and he
said
the people who weep in front of my
paintings are having the same religious
experience that i had while i was making
them
uh i may have gotten that a little wrong
but that was the idea
yeah that is a great one
yeah
to our theme that we've been exploring
about art and religion
so here's a question
[Music]
all right so bittersweet comes out
what
do you think people might gloss over or
under appreciate in the book because i
know if i look back at my various books
and maybe it's only
possible to know that in hindsight but
i'm like god i should have really
emphasized x more
because people didn't pay enough
attention to it or it wasn't sexy enough
and i have examples of those for
many of my books
what do you think is valuable
or important but at risk of perhaps
not being given appropriate attention
anything come to mind
with quiet the book i wrote about the
power of introverts the danger was that
people would think that
i was talking about a kind of
misanthropy you know like not liking
people at all or like a kind of down
with extroverts or something which none
of that was my intention or message
with this book i think the danger is
of people thinking it's a kind of
advocating for a depressive state
and that's really not what i'm talking
about at all it's more like
tell
the truth about what it is like to be
alive and
life is both of these states
simultaneously and it always will be
and i think there's a
tremendous freedom in that and that we
we are basically taught one way or
another that
when things are going well and the
company is doing well the family's happy
and everything
that's the main road and when things go
wrong
it's the detour from the main road
and
just adopting the frame of mind or it to
my mind just accepting the truth that
both of these things are the main road
because that's what life is
it's incredibly liberating
it's incredibly liberating because
you're no longer like fighting against
it
and so much of the stress that we have
is fighting against what's actually true
and feeling like we're alone in it as
opposed to feeling like wow we're all
actually together in this what you just
said about the frame or the lens
of looking at
the
challenges as detours makes me think of
a quote that i i think about a lot
actually to try
to try and i think
build my equanimity to the extent that i
can i think i'm pretty impatient and run
pretty hot not that i yell and scream i
don't but
i can get knocked off
balance by
certain events which is true for
everybody but the quote that i was going
to mention is from jen 11 who's an
astrophysicist who's been on this
podcast
and the quote is i used to resent
obstacles along the path thinking if
only that hadn't happened life would be
so good then i suddenly realized life is
the obstacles there is no underlying
path
and i have found that very freeing
exactly
to revisit and try and embrace
so you have you have
the
roomy poem you've got your husband's
email you
sent me a book of quotes you seem to
like quotes
and sort of condensed wisdom
or encouragement in the case of the
email
do you have any other
quotes that you think of often or that
you've put elsewhere in your house or
anywhere as reminders
do any come to mind well i don't have to
have them come to mind because they're
like taped up all over the place over
here
you want me to pull some down just at
random yes please
okay wait hold on
so
this one is c.s lewis i don't know if
you ever read him but
i mean talk about longing he
he kind of spent his whole life in the
state of what he called the inconsolable
longing for we know not what
and
it's interesting because in his case
he ended up concluding
the way he put it was
if we have this
thirst that can't be satisfied in this
world it must be that we were made for
another divine world and so for him like
he ended up concluding that christianity
was the answer to this insatiable
longing that we all have
i love his work so much i just end up in
a completely different place like to me
when i hear music i'm like oh that's
what people are talking about when they
talk about god it like it is the same
thing to me cs lewis he's the best i
need to read more cs lewis i i remember
and i don't self-identify as a christian
at all
but i read
i've read a lot of his work including
the screwtape letters i don't know if
you
have ever read this i haven't read that
one oh yeah it's i'll let people
investigate but please continue okay i'm
excited to hear
he wrote apparently then
our lifelong nostalgia our longing to be
reunited with something in the universe
from which we now feel cut off to be on
the inside of some door which we have
always seen from the outside is no mere
neurotic fancy but the truest index of
our real situation and to be at last
summoned inside would be both glory and
honor beyond all our merits and also the
healing of that old ache
oh so good i know he's the man i forgot
how good c.s lewis is oh
he's the best
can i ask you a question yes okay
so i feel like you over the last
i don't know how long it's been since
i've been following your work i mean
really from the very beginning when you
first published the four hour work week
i feel like you've really been on a
pathway and over the last
five or more years
you've really been doing this thing of
turning pain into beauty and being
willing to be really open about it
and
i guess i'm curious what made you
shift gears that way
because you kind of started out as like
i'm going to teach you how to be
successful so it's a very different
mode you know
yeah
yeah it's very very different well thank
you for the kind words first
that's
very meaningful i'm not very
yeah i've realized about myself that i i
don't actually
let historically have never let positive
feedback land
i think that goes back a long way so
just wanted to take a second to say that
and as far as the why i mean i think
that
i'm sure
with the caveat that i'm sure i have
many blind spots
in terms of
self-awareness and observation but i
think i think there are a whole lot of
things
first is
being surrounded by
reminders of mortality i've i've lost
a lot of
relatives and close friends to things
like opiate addiction or alcohol
induced cardiomyopathy in the case of my
uncle most recently and
i think that
reminder of impermanence has
led me to explore other things
second would be
recognizing
especially after the success of the
four-hour work week and beginning to
meet people i couldn't have imagined
meeting prior to that i mean people who
have hundreds of millions billions tens
of billions of dollars
that
i well realized many things number one
is that
being pulled towards something
and being driven towards something by
some demon whipping your back are very
different things
and
that many people who are from
any objective external measure the most
successful in the world
got there because they were
in some sense running away from
something not running towards something
yeah
many of the best entrepreneurs i've met
who are also wonderful people and if i'm
going to invest in an entrepreneur
on some level look for this like
they
build
and
scale and so on
as a compulsion it's not a want it's not
a want
people are just like i think i maybe
want to be an entrepreneur for a smaller
side gig that that might work but if
we're looking at people are building
multi-billion dollar companies
they are
compulsively very often compulsively
building
and that is very helpful from the
standpoint of building a huge company
but i think the origins of a lot of
those compulsions
are the same as you would find in ocd or
an eating disorder or
treatment resistant depression where the
compulsive behavior in that case is a
repetitive thought loop or set of
thought loops
so i've i've just i think become a more
nuanced observer of suffering and pain
and trauma then
i would say
having observed that in myself and then
through
various types of therapy but primarily
through psychedelic
assisted therapies
recognized say past sexual abuse which
which i published an episode on
some time ago
which if people want to listen to that
it's not easy listening but i do think
it might be helpful for people with
shared experiences tim.blog trauma which
took me years to get to and i was not
planning on doing anything i was
planning on writing a book after my
parents passed away
having that experience
and
learning to contend or trying to contend
with that
i think has also
made me realize
that
the full spectrum of feeling is
necessary at least for me and my own
personal
path thus far if you want any hope of
reconciliation or finding peace
with some of these these things not
necessarily making meaning of
although one way to make meaning of that
is to as one facilitator said to me you
know make it part of your medicine like
take that pain
take that
take those wounds and make it part of
your medicine so
i do think that that translation has
been
very healing for me personally
and very hard quite frankly right
because
i i get stories and sometimes very
graphic stories and calls for help and
emails and so on
constantly because of talking about
these things publicly
but it's it's no coincidence that i
support
psychedelic related science and have for
quite a few years now
i mean it's got to be millions of
dollars a year at this point through my
foundation this i say foundation
because it literally saved my life and
i've seen it save so many other lives
it's not a panacea there are risks but
for the right indications i think
they're incredibly powerful
so to just add on to that a little bit
and no one's
asked me this publicly so
sorry for the long answer but
when you have these
quintessential psychedelic experiences
which humans have been having for
thousands of years and one could argue
that in fact
our early hominid ancestors
almost certainly
consumed
consciousness altering
plants and fungi as do animals by the
way
to unclear motives right or or reasons
but uh many animals consume
hallucinogens
when you have a classical psychedelic
experience there is very often and i'm
not recommending anyone do this
recreationally because there are severe
risks especially if you have a history
family history of schizophrenia
you very often have the experience
of and i don't know who first said this
to me i may have i may have read it
in rumi or
hafez which is why i'm also drawn to a
lot of
poetry related to mysticism the feeling
of a drop returning to the ocean
yeah
so when you have this experience
of ego dissolution
and
in retrospect after the experience you
imagine that could be the experience
that could have been your experience
putting your in quotation marks
of this kind of non-localized free
floating consciousness before you were
born or after you die and we get into
some very
cuckoo bananas territory as we go out
there but when you when you start
getting into the realm of kind of pan
psychism and
these types of things when you've had
these first-hand experiences
a number of things can happen and at
least have happened to me number one you
get back here and you're like
why am i taking some of this stuff so
[ __ ] seriously i mean seriously i
mean it's just like why
am i taking myself so seriously and this
[ __ ] email so seriously like
it's a joke on some level which can be
demotivating i'm not gonna lie like it
can be hard to like
you know strap down and
bang out
a bunch of email in your inbox when
you're just like this doesn't matter at
all
however you know i think i've tempered
that reasonably well
and
for all of those reasons
i feel like it is my and i'm trying to
actually correct this but on some level
my moral obligation to
share what i have learned
as
trivial as it might be
over the last say 10 years
there are many essential parts of me
that are the same but i've also changed
a lot
and
you know i was
recently i've been sharing a rental with
a friend of mine who's known me since
1998 or 1999
and
he would say having seen like long-term
tim ferriss changes right because we
don't automatically evolve for the
better but the changes he's like you're
pretty much unrecognizable
and
there's certain like
fundamental building blocks that are
still there
but
i know how people who are experiencing
pain or suffering or who have gone
through
perfect trauma i will say it bothers me
that that word is so overused yeah i
agree it's becoming meaningless and when
someone's like oh someone expressed
microaggression on the internet and i'm
so traumatized i get really upset by
that and i do think certain terms should
be reserved for special cases like the
word sacred is another one
so that they retain some semblance of
power and meaning
but let's just say someone has been
sexually abused or has experienced death
there are many different ways to
experience trauma i do think there's a
tendency to
view these things as permanent scars
that you cannot circumvent right it's
like psychic psycho-emotional scar
tissue
that is just part of you from this point
forward and if that causes problems too
bad and you have an excuse
you have a reason you can
compartmentalize it lock it away in this
tight little box in the basement of your
soul and do your best to not
knock it over with your foot in the
middle of the night and
i don't find that works very well
yep
and
these
experiences that we try to suppress or
these feelings that we try to suppress
end up squeezing out of the cracks of
that box we thought it was so tightly
locked inside of and it ends up if not
doing damage to other people just doing
a tremendous amount of damage to us
personally
so any tools
that help
me
to not do that to metabolize these
things to maybe even befriend them and
use them
in some way i feel compelled to share
you know not excessively i still do the
business interviews and i still do talk
about nfts or whatever i still have
other interests but
at the end of the day i think
for a lot of people they climb the
mountain right they realize
that
it doesn't solve all their problems
whether that's like prestige in academia
whatever your currency happens to be
lots of money you may get to a point if
you win the game you're playing where
you realize for [ __ ] sake this
actually doesn't fix anything or fixes
very few things
and so you're gonna have to deal with it
sooner or later and
you know i'll just stop because this is
turned into a ted talk i apologize
that
i think very often about something tara
brock
said to me at one point she shared this
apocryphal story of a sage and the sage
said there's only one question that
really matters and that is what are you
unwilling to feel
and i think about that all the time
i think about that all the time because
i think it applies to so many people in
so many contexts
including myself so
and thankfully
thank
insert god of choice or
universe or
coincidence and just blind luck that
i've i've happened
to come across certain tools that i
think
will probably
in conjunction with other things
completely
change how we view the mind nature of
mind consciousness and certainly
psychiatry and the treatment of what we
consider intractable
psychiatric conditions
because the results
that we're seeing in some of these
studies including phase three studies
these are well-constructed studies
really defy any conventional
explanation that psychiatry can
currently offer yeah right when you have
people with say treatment-resistant ptsd
from
war from rape et cetera who
have
uh and i'm gonna get the numbers
slightly wrong but they're not that far
off
who have something like a median
duration of
diagnosed with ptsd of like 17 plus
years so they've had complex ptsd for
17.2 or however many years on average
they've been taking medication right
treatment resistant generally in this
case means it's failed at least two
different interventions
and they have
two or three sessions of mdma assisted
psychotherapy
and
even say six months later
they have
60 plus percent of them have
who no longer meet the criteria for a
diagnosis of ptsd
that is
staggering i know i've seen some of that
research it's you just can't believe it
which means i think many of the
assumptions that
gird and underlie
our beliefs about
psychiatry and
even
on a on a neurological level i mean just
neuroplasticity the ability to use
compounds whether they are ketamine
which i have some interest in but not
not great interest
or psilocybin more interest
the the actual effects that they have on
neurogenesis right so some of some of
the effects
may be
conferred by
actual structural changes right dendrite
growth as an example but then a lot of
them seem to be determined by content
and rewriting the narratives that govern
our perception and navigation of the
world
and [ __ ] gets really
exciting and wild when you start pulling
on that thread
so
in any case and for people interested in
the mdmas it's psychotherapy there's a
documentary called trip of compassion oh
my gosh i can't i've had that on my list
to do ever since you started
recommending that oh yeah yeah
it's
intense but it's very gratifying and
unlike in the u.s
this documentary because filmed overseas
has actual client footage with client
permission so you get to see
what would be very difficult to get
approval for
due to hipaa and so on in other places
and
that's my ted talk thank you for
listening
well i mean oh my gosh so thank you so
much for
sharing all that
yeah my pleasure if i could say two
things that i i mean there are so many
things that one could say after
everything that you just shared
one is that it's really interesting
[Music]
that you went to that place of like
all the different people who you've met
along the way who
are so successful on the outside and
then
you find what's really driving them
and i actually thought about this this
morning
as i was going through that list of
questions that you ask of like what
would you tell yourself what your 30
year old self or whatever yeah and i had
a few things but one of them was to
understand that all these people who you
meet who seem like
they have it so together they they're so
successful like that that they're all
just humans and i feel like one of the
one of the great privileges of having
written
a book that turned into a bestseller
is that you get to meet all these people
and especially if it's a book like the
kind
that i write people tell you the truth
about what they really feel
and so
now i've heard all these stories and uh
like have just become aware of of all
these dynamics that you're describing
and the second thing i was struck by is
when you talk about that kind of moral
obligation because i have to say like
you know we don't get to talk to each
other that much but i have a sense of
what you're doing through the things you
put into the world and it really feels
like you're driven by that and one of
the things i talk about in the book is
how you know we go through pain and then
there's kind of like a crossroads of
what are you gonna
do with it
if you don't acknowledge it and turn it
into something else you're invariably
gonna take it out as you said on
yourself or on other people
or there's this other
crossroads that you can walk down of
turning it into something else and i
feel like that's what i've been watching
you do for years oh thank you i really
appreciate that yeah it's
i mean i feel like
in a lot of respects
i mean you're you're
you're doing
similar work i mean through your books i
mean you're
conveying truth of human experience
in a way
that
resonates with people who might struggle
otherwise to
identify let alone
express and describe what their internal
experience is and by doing that i think
you are
not just providing a salve
to people
that they don't know they needed
but you're providing a you're providing
language
which is incredibly powerful right i
mean we
i'll say that for another podcast but
you're providing language kind of like
like it's like witchenstein right like
the limits of my language or the limits
of my world i mean i really believe that
so giving someone language is no small
thing
to
label and interact with and convey
and on some level integrate their
experience and then you're giving them
also
empathy
through
the stories that tell them they are not
alone
you're doing a lot of things with your
books that i i respect tremendously and
it's uh i respect it not just because it
is valuable in the world and sorely
needed but because it is [ __ ]
difficult to do
[Laughter]
so i really appreciate the work that
that you do and that you put out in the
world also thank you so much
yeah
susan is there anything else that you
would like to to add
before we
come to a close anything you'd like to
ask my audience anything else
for anybody who is listening today who
feels
moved by what we were talking about or
feels like oh this is me
i guess i just hope that you will
connect with me one way or another
on social or through my book or whatever
so that we can stay in touch that's all
i would say
perfect and i will just say again the
new book is bittersweet
how sorrow and longing make us whole
where you will get to revisit
mononoaware and all sorts of good things
and i really really believe in
the building of one's
emotional vocabulary and range i think
it
not only gives you a richer experience
of life but it
it creates a certain anti-fragility i
think
that
to life's
inevitable ups and downs so i do think
this is an important book so bittersweet
is the book
people can find you susan kane
c-a-a-i-n-dot-net susan kane.net on
twitter susan kane facebook author susan
kane linkedin susan kane instagram susan
kane author will link to everything
including
this amazing playlist that i must get my
hands on so we will also put the
playlist
in the show notes team.logs slash
podcast just search susan and it will
pop
right up
and i would say to everyone listening
till next time
be a little kinder than you think
necessary both to
yourself and to others
and thank you so much for tuning in
you